les employés de la fonction publique
québécoise gagne moins que les autres
salariés québécois l'Institut de la
statistique calcul que leur rémunération
globale est 3,9% inférieures l'écart est
de plus de 20% par rapport aux employés
des autres administrations publiques qui
incluent les municipalités le
gouvernement fédéral même les
fonctionnaires québécois mais les
fonctionnaires québécois gagnent quand
même 3,9% plus que les travailleurs du
secteur privé quand on isole vraiment
avec le secteur privé on a on a le
plaisir de recevoir ce soir Caroline
Senneville la présidente de la CSN
bonsoir bonsoir on vous retrouve à
Québec parce que vous avez assisté au
discours du Premier ministre le goût qui
a salué aujourd'hui le travail des
fonctionnaires et il a dit aussi qu'il
voulait embaucher plus de travailleurs
en santé comment vous réagissez à ça
d'abord
je suis contente qu'il est aussi des
faits limite par rapport au
fonctionnariat puis il faut faire la
distinction par exemple la fonction
publique et l'administration publique
quand on parle d'administration publique
et des services publics ça compte les
écoles les cégep effectivement là puis
tout le système de santé de service
sociaux donc oui on a bien on a bien
noté ça puis dans la santé écouter c'est
pas moi qui doit se réjouir c'est la
population du Québec
parce que les besoins sont immenses
c'est vrai les besoins sont immenses
mais par exemple quand ils parlent
d'ajouter du personnel en santé je
présume que c'est de la musique à vos
oreilles
mais encore une fois c'est de la musique
à nos oreilles si ça vient décharger la
tâche des gens le temps supplémentaire
obligatoire qui est de plus en plus
demandée les charges qui s'alourdissent
des personnes qui s'absentent et qui ne
sont pas remplacées on le vu là moi je
mets au défi je vous mets au défi même
votre équipe de trouver plusieurs types
d'emplois dans le secteur public où il y
a pas de difficulté de recrutement et ça
c'est un impact sur les tâches puis sur
la charge de travail puis surtout
surtout sur les services à la population
il a évoqué la possibilité la
construction de deux mini hôpitaux
privés est-ce que est-ce que vous
réagissez à ça que de voir le privé
grandir dans le secteur de santé c'est
pas une bonne nouvelle c'est vraiment
pas une bonne nouvelle surtout c'est du
privé pour profit je vois pas pourquoi
l'argent de nos impôts servirait à
financer des profits des gens qui
veulent justement faire de l'argent avec
la maladie des gens le privé on va se le
dire aussi
c'est des s'ils sont à ce qui est rapide
facile pas trop complexe et peu coûteux
et quelquefois d'augmenter la part du
privé ça vient pas alléger la tâche du
public mais au contraire ça vient
l'alourdir parce que les colours tombent
là et le privé vous savez quand ils sont
pas capables de répondre à la commande
ben il s'enlève les mains puis il
l'envoie au public qui lui n'a pas le
choix de se dire l'ensemble de la
population pour vous non le gouvernement
a dit aujourd'hui du Premier ministre a
dit qu'il veut atteindre l'équilibre
budgétaire et là ça arrive le davantage
en discours des scènes finances
publiques est-ce que vous entendez un
message du gouvernement qu'on ne peut
pas aller plus loin dans le cadre par
exemple des négociations avec le front
commun syndical
écoutez on est peut-être à la croisée
des chemins on a un choix à faire puis
parler il a parlé aussi de baisse
d'impôts puis je l'ai dit je le répète
soit pour moi c'est quelque chose de
vraiment irresponsable par la des
parents là qui sont pas capables d'avoir
accès à un médecin puis leur enfant de
la fièvre s'ils veulent le retour
d'impôts s'ils veulent un système de
santé qui fonctionne parler à des
parents qui ont des jeunes à l'école qui
ça fonctionne pas puis qu'ils ont besoin
de professionnels pour les aider par là
des gens qui ont pas accès à des
services de garde parler à des gens qui
ont des problèmes de santé mentale
on a qu'à passer au service sociaux au
service à la jeunesse on a vécu des
drames alors qu'est-ce que c'est tout ça
dans la balance par rapport au baisse
d'impôts
en même temps c'est l'engagement de ce
gouvernement de baisser les impôts
on verra de toute façon ça va venir dans
le budget il nous reste un petit peu de
temps pour parler sur le plan salarial
les données qui ont été publiées
aujourd'hui
de l'Institut de la statistique montre
que les employés de la fonction publique
de l'administration québécoise gagne
moins que les autres salariés même si la
situation c'est quand même un peu
améliorée on parle quand même d'un écart
qui va jusqu'à 12% si je tiens pas
compte des avantages sociaux c'était car
là est-il encore trop grand aujourd'hui
et surtout qu'est-ce qu'il provoque il
provoque que on manque de gens dans les
services publics on est par rapport aux
autres services plus des sociétés d'État
la fonction publique municipale fédérale
on est les cancres alors si vous êtes un
employé de soutien par exemple pourquoi
j'irai travailler dans une
administration dans l'administration
québécoise si je peux gagner plus
d'argent ailleurs puis j'aimerais dire
que quand vous dites on gagne plus que
le privé attention les gens de
l'administration publique québécoises
gagnent encore moins que le privé
syndiqué alors c'est quand on évidemment
le privé non syndiqué dans le moins que
les gens de l'administration publique et
quand on fait la malgame des deux ça
donne ça mais quand on compare même
privé syndiqué avec l'administration
publique c'est pas l'administration
publique organique en ce moment des
employés de l'administration publique
absolument 0 à proximité puis pas grand
chose pour les retenir et le salaire
serait une solution à la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre serait la bonne solution
d'augmenter les salaires déterminants
certainement si vous êtes capable de
faire exactement le même travail ou un
travail semblable avec 10% de salaire
ailleurs écouter le choix vite fait
est-ce que vos attentes changent avec
les données de l'ISQ aujourd'hui non
parce que il y a pénurie de main
d'oeuvre parce que les services publics
ont vraiment besoin puis le Premier
ministre lui-même a dit qu'il fallait
qu'il engage d'autres personnes ça sera
pas par
magie puis parce que l'inflation
galopante aussi et c'est jamais le tour
des employés du service des services
publics on a vécu des années vraiment de
famine on s'est appauvris dans les
dernières années dans les dernières
décennies et puis il faut que cette
spirale là soit inversée parce que sinon
il n'y arrivera pas merci Madame
Senneville d'avoir été avec nous merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI